[Musica]
io sono reduce da un recente trasloco
padova e nelle ultime settimane non so
bene come ho trovato su una scrivania
una vecchia targa fatta di legno di
cedro che arriva dal libano mi hanno
detto che questo tipo di albero è
simbolo di immortalità e di eternità e
credo che avere ritrovato questo vecchio
cimelio sia importante questa targa mi è
stata regalata diversi anni fa dal papà
di un bambino molto speciale che si
chiama mohamed noi lo abbiamo sempre
chiamato a mou di lui è speciale perché
il primo vino al mondo ad aver ricevuto
una nuova terapia che oggi speriamo si
sta avviando a diventare un farmaco per
curare una malattia devastante questa
malattia ha portato via i fratelli più
grandi di a mou di una possibilità di
discutere di questa targa oggi credo che
sia legata al fatto che sulla targa
oltre al suo nome al mio nome ci sono
due date la prima è la data di nascita
di hamoudi la seconda è la data della
sua rinascita cioè del giorno in cui il
3 di maggio del 2010 ha ricevuto questa
opportunità a questo trattamento che gli
ha dato la possibilità di un futuro
oggi lui a 10 anni vive vicino a milano
si è trasferito dal libano va a scuola
parla tre lingue parla arabo francese e
parla italiano
tutte cose che i suoi fratelli non
avrebbero mai potuto fare la sua
rinascita si basa sul dna che questo
elemento così prezioso il nostro
patrimonio genetico che è contenuto
all'interno di ogni cellula del nostro
organismo
il patrimonio genetico è composto dna
che è formato da tante lettere che si
ripetono in un ordine molto preciso le
lettere che compongono il nostro
patrimonio genetico e che dicono chi
siamo e come siamo fatti sono circa 3
miliardi quindi in ogni cellula del
nostro corpo ci sono tre miliardi di
lettere sono tante sono tante
soprattutto se pensiamo che ogni giorno
devono essere ricopiate moltissime
volte il nostro patrimonio genetico deve
essere duplicato ogni giorno noi
perdiamo tra i 50 e 100 milioni di
cellule che naturalmente muoiono e che
devono essere rinnovate e ognuna
contiene 3 milioni di lettere 3 miliardi
di lettere in ogni modalità di
trasmissione della vita in ognuno dei
nostri gameti che può trasmettere il
nostro patrimonio genetico si deve
realizzare lo stesso esercizio di
copiatura è ovvio che un esercizio così
importante una copiatura così costante
di così tante lettere può comportare
degli errori e fisiologico che ogni
tanto ci sia un errore una lettera
sbagliata nella gran parte dei casi
questi errori nelle nostro codice
genetico sono del tutto neutrali non
causano nessuna conseguenza ma non è
sempre così
se questi errori di copiatura vengono
negati possono determinare delle
condizioni che sono chiamate malattie
genetiche
c'è un genere a cui sequenza non è più
quella originale quella normale e questo
può causare una malattia
se questo errore di copiatura avviene in
un'altra cellula del nostro corpo in una
cellula somatica le conseguenze di nuovo
possono non esserci
oppure questa alterazione che noi
chiamiamo mutazione può contribuire
insieme ad altre insieme a fattori
ambientali alla comparsa di malattie
molto comuni che vanno dal diabete
dall'ipertensione alle malattie
cardiovascolari
quindi nel dna non c'è solo la chiave di
chi siamo ma anche di molte delle nostre
malattie l'opportunità che oggi abbiamo
è di utilizzare dna anche come strumento
di pura quindi per risolvere queste
patologie e lo possiamo fare attraverso
una modalità di cura che si chiama
terapia genica e che si basa
sostanzialmente nella possibilità di
introdurre nelle cellule del nostro
organismo nelle cellule malate
nelle sequenze di dna che sostituiscono
o riparano gli errori di copiatura
queste mutazioni
come possiamo farlo be la chiave è
trovare un
lo strumento una capsula un vettore che
trasporti in modo efficace questi
segmenti di dna all'interno delle nostre
cellule nel nucleo è fatto sì che queste
nuove informazioni permangano nel lungo
termine all'interno del nostro organismo
ci sono diversi tipi di vettori che
possono essere utilizzati in modo
diverso la forma più comune che più è
utilizzata soprattutto nella pratica
clinica si basa sull'uso di virus virus
naturali che sono particolarmente
efficaci come sappiamo ogni volta che
prendiamo raffreddore sono
particolarmente efficaci nell entrare
nelle nostre cellule e replicarsi
all'interno delle nostre cellule
bè noi abbiamo imparato a rendere questi
virus innocui e a utilizzare la loro
capacità per trasportare il dna che noi
intendiamo come strumento curativo nelle
nostre cellule stesse
immagino che a al vostro ascolto di
persone che ovviamente non sono
coinvolti in prima persona nello
sviluppo di queste terapie tutto questo
sembra un pochino difficile quanto meno
tecnologico complesso artificioso in
realtà senz'altro ci sono delle
difficoltà ma ci sono anche delle grandi
potenzialità e possibilità di realizzare
questo percorso complesso e queste
possibilità e potenzialità sono
dimostrate da questo grafico che vi fa
vedere quante sperimentazioni cliniche
basate sul trasporto di dna delle
cellule basate sulla terapia genica si
sono sviluppate e sono state condotte
negli ultimi trent'anni
molti pazienti sono stati oggetti di
questa sperimentazione ma soprattutto
vedete un trend in crescita quindi a
partire dalla fine degli anni 80 ad oggi
abbiamo avuto una progressiva crescita
del numero di studi clinici che ha
cercato di valutare se questo tipo di
terapia potesse essere fattibile sicura
ed efficace e quindi e quindi oggi
possiamo dire che effettivamente questo
tipo di terapia e fattibile e negli
ultimi dieci anni siamo riusciti a
dimostrare che ha un impatto perché è
fattibile ma
di sicurezza per i pazienti e può
determinare un beneficio per i nostri
pazienti quindi una terapia che nelle
condizioni in cui fino ad oggi è stata
testata può essere estremamente efficace
e ha potuto offrire un futuro libero di
malattia a centinaia di pazienti con
malattie genetiche come a muri di cui
parlavamo prima o pazienti affetti da
tumori vi faccio qualche esempio che
penso possa aiutarvi a capire di cosa
stiamo parlando
una delle prime condizioni su cui la
terapia genica è stata testata e
sviluppata fa capo a queste sindromi che
si chiamavano i bambini bolle bubble boy
disease's condizioni in cui a causa di
nuovo di errori nel patrimonio genetico
di mutazioni nascono dei bambini che
sono privi di difese immunitarie e
quindi che non sono in grado di
difendersi da batteri virus e infezioni
comuni come il morbillo o un raffreddore
o un'influenza è bene per loro queste
infezioni non solo diventano importanti
ma potenzialmente possono essere anche
causa di morte precoce proprio per
proteggerli da questi eventi in passato
questi bambini vivevano in ambienti
protetti in ambienti sterili e da qui il
nome appunto dei bambini bolla bene nel
2019 oggi questi bambini possono vivere
fuori dalle bolle grazie a diversi tipi
di trattamento ma grazie anche alla
terapia genica ci sono i primi farmaci
registrati per questi bambini che si
basano su un trapianto di cellule del
sangue che ricostituiscano l'immunità le
difese immunitarie di questi pazienti e
non sono cellule del sangue di un
donatore sano come nella trapiantologia
più tradizionale sono le cellule del
sangue del paziente che sono prelevate
ingegnerizzata in laboratorio e ridate
ai bambini malati
in questo modo i bambini rinascono ad un
futuro libero dalle costrizioni della
malattia che erano condannati
queste sono malattia molto rara questa
terapia può essere efficace anche per
condizioni più comuni e forse un pochino
più vicina all'esperienza quotidiana di
tutti penso che tutti sappiate
che la talassemia e drepanocitosi sono
forme di anemia sono abbastanza diffuse
soprattutto nelle nostre regioni e sono
malattie molto invalidanti hanno delle
modalità di cura che possono ovviamente
migliorare la prognosi dei pazienti ma
che hanno dei limiti limiti in termini
di efficacia e durabilità
anche per questi pazienti la terapia
genica il trapianto di cellule staminali
del sangue che sono state modificate
geneticamente è un'opportunità è un
opportunità di cura e di nuovo di un
futuro libero da malattia
un altro esempio a questo punto parliamo
di una delle condizioni morbose più
severe e ahimé i comuni nell'infanzia le
leucemie acute del bambino sono la forma
più comune di tumori per i bambini sono
una malattia importante con un grosso
impatto anche dal punto di vista sociale
e culturale
le leucemie sono delle malattie da cui
oggi molti bambini possono guarire
l'ottanta per cento dei bambini con una
prima diagnosi di leucemia guarisce e
trattata dalle terapie tradizionali ma
un 20 per cento di questi bambini ricade
e quindi a distanza di anni potrà di
nuovo sviluppare lo stesso tumore per
questi bambini la prognosi è molto
peggiore la loro sopravvivenza
a un anno dalla diagnosi della ripresa
del tumore è del 20 per cento significa
che i 100 bambini che hanno una ripresa
di malattia
a distanza di un anno da questa ripresa
soltanto 20 saranno vivi e saranno
sopravvissuti alla malattia
bene con la terapia genica in
particolare con una forma di terapia
genica di cui forse qualcuno ha sentito
parlare
le cellule carthy possiamo cambiare
sostanzialmente la prognosi di questi
pazienti
gli stessi pazienti con una ripresa di
tumore dopo le terapie tradizionali
possono avere un beneficio sostanziale e
80 dei 100 colpiti da questa condizione
potranno essere ancora vivi a un anno
dopo il trattamento
questo perché perché abbiamo in questo
caso ingegno
realizzato inserito dei geni funzionali
all'interno delle loro cellule del
sistema immunitario per rendere capace
di trovare il tumore riconoscerlo e
uccidere le cellule portatrici di
malattia
questi sono numeri a mio avviso
importanti e sono numeri importanti per
tutta la comunità scientifica che sta
guardando questi nuovi farmaci che
arrivano sul mercato con grande
aspettativa ma restano numeri e quindi
ho pensato per darvi veramente il senso
della potenzialità di quello di cui
stiamo parlando di farvi vedere qualcosa
di un pochino più concreto di farvi
toccare con mano l'esperienza di una
famiglia e di alcuni pazienti che sono
affetti dalla stessa malattia di hamoudi
del bambino di cui parlavamo all'inizio
che ha un nome abbastanza
impronunciabile per i più che noi
chiamiamo oggi mld
è una malattia devastante che colpisce
il sistema nervoso di questi piccoli
pazienti e li porta ad una condizione di
incapacità di muoversi di comunicare di
parlare e di vedere in pochi mesi dalla
diagnosi
io vi racconto la storia di tre bambini
in questo video che sono colpiti da
questa malattia
liviana giovanni e sicilia sono bambini
con nomi italiani sono americani ma
hanno trovato almeno due di loro hanno
trovato la loro rinascita in italia
grazie alla terapia genica file
ap i giovani ei giovani
damon pure l'altro il bari
credo che questo video vi possa avere
comunicato quali sono le potenzialità la
potenzialità di ridare la possibilità
per un futuro dei bambini con malattie
mortali la possibilità di dargli
l'opportunità di rinascere alla vita
ovviamente le potenzialità sono grandi
devono essere dimostrate e riverificate
per ogni nuova condizione che vorremmo
affrontare con questa forma di terapia e
devono essere sempre guardate con
l'occhio critico di di chianche
consapevole di tutte le criticità che
sono associate ad ogni terapia ed in
particolare ad ogni terapia innovativa
come tutti i farmaci anche la terapia
genica ha degli effetti collaterali non
c'è nessun farmaco che non ne abbia la
cosa importante è conoscere il proprio
farmaco conoscere non solo le sue
potenzialità ma anche le sue criticità
conoscere la tecnologia che c'è alla
base di entrambe ed essere in grado di
ottimizzare l'efficacia intervenendo in
maniera mirata su tutti quelli che sono
gli aspetti potenzialmente suscettibili
di miglioria per ridurre i rischi
le criticità sono anche insite nella
tecnologia che c'è alla base di questa
modalità di trattamento una tecnologia
che ovviamente difficile da esportare
sui grandi numeri una tecnologia che ha
dei costi importanti e quindi la
consapevolezza di tutti gli operatori
del settore che queste sono aree su cui
intervenire ed a migliorare ci
permetterà con il tempo di rendere
questo tipo di terapia non sono
applicabili ai più ma anche fruibile da
pazienti che non sono solo affetti da
malattie rare ma da malattie più comuni
e quindi la sfida per noi oggi e non
solo di dare una possibilità di
rinascita e di cura bambini come
mohammad giovanni eccessivi a che hanno
malattie rare ma anche di offrire
un'opportunità a pazienti con malattie
più comuni la nuova sfida sono le
diabete la sclerosi multipla
l'ipertensione e il cancro
[Applauso]